une augmentation de 150 euros brut par
mois pour les ouvriers
c'est la revendication de ses salariés
de la fromagerie bel le groupe a débuté
ses négociations annuelles obligatoires
les propositions de la direction sont
trop faibles pour les syndicats il ya eu
des propositions faites par la direction
mais qui sont très très faible comme
prime de transport
l'augmentation d'un point 4% alors qu'on
les rende une inflation de 1,8
intersyndicale était parti pour la cgt à
150 euros pour le reste sur une base de
5 %
donc on est loin du compte donc
aujourd'hui on initie un moment grève
pour appuyer la prochaine réunion de
négociation
après on verra pour la suite les
grévistes s'appuie aussi sur les
revendications des gilets jaunes une
meilleure distribution des bénéfices et
plus de pouvoir d'achat on attend une
augmentation correct qui nous puisse
permettre qu'ils puissent nous permettre
de vivre correctement de pouvoir finir
les fans mois avait mis les milieux moi
même on va dire parce que c'est plus les
fans mois au 15 du mois voilà des
salariés du site de lons le saunier se
mobiliseront à leur tour le 14 mars et
négociations se poursuivront la semaine
prochaine
la direction n'a quant à elle pas
souhaité s'exprimer